it has been three weeks since ccsd
superintendent dr jesus jarrow was fired
the school board voted overnight to
offer him his job back and victoria saha
now with his response and what happens
next
to stay or not to stay is the question
everyone is waiting dr jesus jarrod to
answer thursday night's meeting ended
with a 4-3 vote wiping out that october
28 termination of dr jarrah trustee
irene cepeda reversed her original vote
of firing him i voted thinking maybe
they have a plan but there was no plan
parent rebecca garcia is echoing those
concerns it was obvious that the board
again
was fractured and not
really willing or able to communicate
with each other making it very hard to
make a plan to get a new superintendent
but with the new leader or not garcia is
concerned history will repeat itself if
a new person is coming into the same
situation are they going to be able to
succeed
and dr jar returning to the same
situation is that going to be positive
either board president linda cavazos
voted to terminate dr jarrah's contract
twice she tweeted shortly after the
meeting saying i didn't lose anything
tonight the students employees and
community whose voices were ignored are
the ones who lost victoria saha live
local now
even if dr jarrah does accept his job
back he will be paid out close to one
million dollars of his contract and
through his attorneys he's asking for
two million claiming the board's actions
were malicious dr jarrah did release the
following statement saying in part he is
working with legal counsel he hopes to
work with the board and attorneys to
determine a path that would allow him to
continue as superintendent